le coc vite 19 qui a fait 18 morts
supplémentaires en france lors des
dernières 24 heures pour traiter la
maladie l'union européenne autorise
depuis hier leur md sivir antiviral du
laboratoire américain gilead premier
remède autorisée sur le vieux continent
alors que les etats-unis ont acheté le
stock mondial de ce médicament dont le
prix a été fixé cette semaine à 2340
dollar sur le sol américain une
autorisation conditionnelle qui aurait
donné des résultats encourageants chez
des patients hospitalisés alors que
certains experts assurent que leur md y
virent ne garantit pas une guérison
totale
une décision qui intervient deux jours
après l'altercation à distance entre
professeur didier raoult et fervent
défenseur de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
molécules peu coûteuse utilise également
contre le koala virus et martin hirsch
le directeur général de l'ap-hp et en
direct dans ce gîte et étienne de
creully la microbiologiste et directeur
de recherche au cnrs à marseille
bonjour etienne le produit merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
le feu vert de la commission européenne
une semaine seulement après la
recommandation de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments contre 67 jour en temps
normal
comment expliquer cette précipitation
alors que nombre d'experts estiment
qu'il ne s'agit pas du remède miracle et
bonjour oui effectivement c'est le délai
a été extrêmement court mais ce qu'il
faut voir évidemment c'est que la
pandémie est toujours en cours de
manière très importante entre autres aux
états unis et donc il ya urgence
évidemment avoir des premières
thérapeutique qui soit mise sur le
marché donc par ailleurs effectivement
ça n'est pas une molécule miracle parce
que les résultats des études cliniques
ont été très discutée et ont montré si
l'on montré des effets significatifs sur
la réduction de la quantité de virus
chez les patients qui étaient amoindris
nettement plus touchés les patients qui
traitait l'effet thérapeutique
significatifs restent limités et donc
c'est probablement le premier médicament
d'une liste qui va s'allonger parce qu'à
d'autres molécules qui sont en piste
pour éventuellement arriver dans des
sorties d'essai clinique pour pouvoir
être disponible chez patients et donc ce
qu'il faut imaginer évidemment c'est que
ça montre le succès finalement
des programmes de recherche qui
maintenant petit à petit vont commencer
à pouvoir délivrer des premières
thérapeutique qui vont être associés
vraiment aux différents stades de la
maladie dans des thérapeutiques qui
seront plutôt pour la phase précoce la
verrez ni mais également des
thérapeutiques probants pour traiter de
la tempête si technique qui est la
deuxième phase de la maladie qui pose un
grave problème pour laquelle il y aura
proment des hymnes mobilisateur qui vont
pouvoir être repositionné de manière à
traiter les patients tiennent du
courrier vous venez de parler d'un effet
à thérapeutique mitigé de la part du
rêve d hiver pourquoi alors l'union
européenne valide ce médicament sur quoi
se base t elle alors que les essais vous
l'avez dit ont été effectués par centre
médical américain les états unis
d'ailleurs qui achètent un le stock
mondial de rêve d hiver bah oui parce
qu'il faut faire un feu tout à d'une
certaine manière et que donc pour
l'instant en l'absence d'autres
thérapeutique qui est clairement validé
et bien le set de dhimmi la charge
virale secteu manque quelque chose qui
est assez important parce que ça diminue
la transmission du virus d'une part et
puis parce que on va pouvoir cette fois
ci la voir des cohortes de patients
suffisamment important pour avoir des
effets statistiques tout à fait précis
et puis qu'on va prendre mon également
s'engager dans des stratégies qui vont
et de thérapeutique dual ou multiple où
on a vraiment associé de ces
thérapeutiques à d'autres
expérimentations de manière justement à
pouvoir à la fois contrôler la réaction
biologique mais également la capacité de
réplication du virus et donc faut voir
ça en fait dans un processus
lorem d hiver un antiviral du
laboratoire américain gilead qui a fixé
le prix en europe à 2000 76 euros un
prix dixit gilead pour les pays
développés du monde entier afin de créer
un modèle à prix unique en face on sait
qu'il ya l'hydroxyde l'origine peu
coûteuse
un antiviral également qui a fait
baisser la charge virale sur le
professeur raoul tu sur les dix premiers
jours de l'infection que répondez vous à
ceux qui pensent que l'industrie
pharmaceutique cherche à discréditer le
plaquer nil c'est à dire les toxiques
loire utile pour des questions d'argent
alors moi je veux absolument pas rentrer
dans la polémique de savoir si c'est une
guerre de l'industrie pharmaceutique qui
est en jeu je crois que ce qu'il faut
raison garder et que la science en fête
repose sur des évidences robuste est
donc actuellement il ya beaucoup de
contestations en ce qui concerne la
chloroquine et donc il faut attendre que
les études expérimentales et statistique
suffisante avec des essais angoula blog
démontre l'efficacité pour
éventuellement revenir ou abandonner les
essais ce match au rocking vous parlez
de faire tomber un set cette charge
virale justement le professeur à août
selon lui avec l'hydro xi chloroquine la
charge virale ps notamment sur les dix
premiers jours alors pourquoi l'union
européenne ne ne panique pas également
la commercialisation ou en tous les cas
l'aval pour pour les tories ses couleurs
reviennent en europe alors que moi je ne
fais pas partie de la commission
européenne donc je peux pas vous donner
les réponses mais en tout cas ce que je
vois c'est que dans la littérature il ya
beaucoup de discussions en ce qui
concerne les c de la chloroquine et donc
il faut attendre qu'il ya consensus qui
se dégage des essais cliniques de
manière à ce que la commission
européenne puisse prendre une décision
j'imagine en ayant des éléments factuels
suffisamment probants de manière à
pouvoir avancer dans ce dossier
accélération de l'épidémie de virus aux
états unis en amérique latine en inde
également à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre pour cet automne en france
alors c'est très difficile de faire des
prévisions mais des prévisions mais ce
qu'on sait c'est que bon les maladies
virales sont souvent des maladies qui
ont des cycles infectieux et dans la
mesure où actuellement on voit que le
contrôle
irini est extrêmement complexe donc aux
états unis notamment
ça indique que le virus il va continuer
à circuler sur le territoire
donc si on rouvre
les frontières vont pas s'attendre à
voir une réelle porte à sion de cas
relativement importante en france et en
europe et donc avoir des difficultés à
contrôler l'épidémie avec des retours
soit sous forme d'une valve dans le camp
serait en difficulté de contrôler soit
sous le forme de cas qui vont se
redévelopper avec des clusters qui vont
arriver et la capacité du système de
santé en tulle mois par une détection
massive mais également la capacité à
isoler les patients qui seraient dictés
j'insiste là dessus c'est très important
il faut que la détection soit associée
au fait que les patients soient isolés
par en vous aidant les familles parce
que 95% des contaminations sont
intrafamiliales donc il faut qu'une fois
qu'une personne soit détectée on les
envoie dans des structures dédiées qui
ne doivent pas être nécessairement des
hôpitaux de manille à être isolé pendant
la période où ils sont contagieuses
c'est comme ça qu'on va être en capacité
de contrôler l'épidémie isolés et
traités 1
évidemment que ce soit le rem divise ir
ou l'idrac cyclone chinois ou un autre
médicament mais au final dans cet
imbroglio qui croirait est ce que vous
êtes confiant quant à un traitement
prochain efficace à 100% sans aucune
polémique
oui les choses avancent mais il faut
laisser le temps au temps parce que une
étude clinique ça prend du temps
avoir des résultats statistiques
significatives ça prend du temps et tout
ne se fait pas dans l'urgence est donc
les contient des morts et a justement il
ne faut pas être dans l'urgence quand il
ya tant de morts non je crois pas qu'il
faut être dans l'urgence c'est le le
métier des médecins s'est effectivement
c'est l'urgence et d'avoir des
traitements supporter if etc
mais l'identification de nouveaux
médicaments doit se faire avec sérénité
de manière à ce qu'on s'assure de ne pas
le mettre sur le marché des médicaments
qui pourraient avoir des toxicités
éventuellement chez les patients et
d'essai adverse qui pourrait être
complètement contre-productif et donc il
faut prendre le temps de faire les
choses sérieusement et faire confiance
aux médecins qui eux ronde et arsenal
thérapeutique supporter ifs en attendant
le fait d'avoir des molécules dont la
sécurité est absolument démontrer
merci à dien de crawley d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes microbiol
liszt et directeur de recherche au cnrs
à marseille